welcome the costars of Austin Powers The
Spy Who shagged me Mike Myers and
Heather Graham
we're here to present the award for best
achievement in sound the most important
element of sound is consistency
sometimes it's as simple as a mole
connected otherwise an actor can give a
brilliant performance and still end up
looking like a big hole come on Mike
epic thank you here are the nominees
Robert jail it Elliott Tyson Michael
Hrbek and Willie D Burton for the Green
Mile Andy Nelson Doug Hemphill and Lee
Orloff for the insider john Reich's greg
rule off David Campbell and David Lee
for the matrix
Leslie Schatz Chris Carpenter Rick Klein
and Kris Munroe for the money
Gary Rydstrom Tom Johnson Sean Murphy
and John Mitchell for Star Wars Episode
one with the Phantom Menace
and the Oscar goes to John writes Greg
would love penny Campbell Kennedy for
the matrix
this is the first Academy Award
right David Campbell and David Lee a new
blog who won an Oscar in 1989 for glory
over here Wow
this little guy represents so much hard
work by so many people we're very proud
to be able to represent them tonight
there's too many to thank individually
but we do want to thank the Wachowski
brothers Joel silver for being just a
wonderful experience they're a lot of
fun to work with and Joel we truly
appreciate all your trust and support
thank you very much
thank you Joe